welcome back to New rockstars the Ahsoka
finale is hours away right now it's
crazy and we still have no idea how Dave
filoni plans to wrap this thing up so
today we are going to talk about how
this show could end what Mysteries might
go unresolved one which ones might
finally get answered and all of our
final major question marks before
Tuesday's finale of Ahsoka this is a new
show on new rock stars that we're
calling the sneak peek where we take the
temperature of whatever we're watching
while we head into the next episode or
look ahead to the next week in nerdum
I'm Eric Voss and joining me is Tommy
bechtels galaxy far far away sneak peeks
from a sneak freaks here we go what's
gonna happen sneaking around what am I
in high school again I'm so glad to be
here with you Eric you know I'll do you
even call the show whatever we want but
when it's you and I I simply call it
Rowan down
thrown down with my butt I'm so glad
that you and I have had some
opportunities to talk about Ahsoka this
season over on the break room channel
it's always been like a blast I'm sorry
I've been so sleep deprived I feel like
okay we've talked about it oh yeah no
problem absolutely no problem all right
I'll take you in any condition you know
fully rested sleep deprived
three-quarter Shields thirty percent
Shields at eight percent I can handle it
let's let's talk about
on on the calendar right now this Ahsoka
finale uh Tommy what are your biggest
questions heading into this final
episode all right so here's my biggest
question going into the finale Eric
there are a lot of story lines that need
to be wrapped up but specifically Baylor
how are they gonna wrap up his story
when there seems to be so much ground to
cover and you know there's the
unfortunate reality of the real life
actor what what do you think what do you
think is are we gonna see a full story
arc yeah I you know we got to pour one
out for Ray Stevenson he did so good on
this show and like whatever whatever
happens with this character in the
finale I think he just deserves a stand
you know for everything he did yeah and
I'm I'm still trying to figure out I
mean I love being in this state of
mystery uh because on one hand it seems
like he is the most mysterious character
the one character who's like a central
Journey we're still asking a lot of
questions at about and he really could
go to any number of interesting hidden
powers in the Star Wars Universe we've
talked about bendu we've talked about
the gods of mortis specifically the
father or the son of mortis who might
live on in some form or abaloth the
mother figure from Star Wars Legends who
kind of served them there's a Wellspring
priestesses and I feel like I might be
the only one who talks about here
there's uh there's like zepho and kujit
you know from from the Ancient Ancient
past yeah um I'm also though wondering
if the reason why we've seen so much of
valence skull is they just included
every wonderful take of Ray Stevenson
because they knew this is his final role
and then now they're kind of setting him
up to be an interesting character
because they want to show all this great
acting but we might not get some big
answers about what is calling to him we
might just hear like a voice that's a
whisper in his head and then he kind of
goes off into the sunset and that's it
yeah I I I I agree with that last
sentiment that is uh I think first of
all that's a wonderful Instinct for the
for the creatives to have had given the
performance I also I think they have
done a nice job of setting up that he
sees and end to his master Apprentice
relationship with you know like
clearly the episode seven there's like
there's a literal separation and he
gives her party he even says this is my
last lesson or one last lesson or
something like that so you know I I
think you're right we may not get like
this satisfying conclusion to the
character but I do think that not to be
cliche the Journey of the character has
been the the reward and I hope you know
via
um
you know the art comic books and and
novelizations and and video games or
whatever animation we can that character
Ray Stevenson breathe life into it that
I think it can live on in other
iterations uh as a tribute to him rather
than being you know rather than there
being a um
uh just a kind of like hard stuff so so
yes more Balin please but bail us out
because I need more Balin I'm I'm
barkers for bailin uh all right so
here's my other question because a great
fear of mine as you know Eric is my fear
of Abandonment so who's getting off
peridia the purple seem to have just
bounced which I could understand when
you send a bunch of uh World War II
bomber ships uh to
start shooting at them they bounced also
I I know that that this wasn't the
effect them bouncing made me laugh so
hard like that like that scene I know it
was supposed to be kind of funny hu Yang
being like the program are offering
cover and then I'm just going
was yeah yeah so I don't think yeah yeah
I don't think thrawn is uh selling
tickets for the Star Destroyer for rides
it's not elon's uh hyperloop in Vegas
where you can uh you could ride in a
tiny Tesla for two minutes but I yeah
who's getting off peridia I think
they're all getting off peridia I think
this episode is gonna I think the finale
episode's gonna take us back to the Star
Wars Main Galaxy because I don't think
we're done with Hera and Jason yet uh I
don't think we're done with like even
ziono and uh maybe maybe we're done with
ziono and mon mothma but I feel like we
gotta have hair we gotta have Zeb like
they wouldn't have created Zeb for for
the Mandalorian we'll talk about cameos
in a second but yeah I think they're all
getting off the prettier they're all
getting out of this Galaxy and we might
have like a final battle or like the
setup of a future season that's setting
uh things up in the main Galaxy on like
the planet of dathomir or something like
that my hope is that the final shot of
the Season uh is something either of
Ezra on lothal or thrawn on deathmere
yeah
well either one would be be throwing you
now you kind of alluded to this in your
answer but do you think filoni is going
to get the whole Rebels game together is
there a chance we get a Canaan Forest
ghost we already talked about Zab which
I you know I've come a long way on Sam
you know through watching all of rebels
for for a project for the channel I I
went from being a Zeb uh hater to a Zeb
uh okay here I I now kind of enjoy
something
yeah I mean it's uh what a mess he is in
throughout Rebels he's just he gets
shamed for his stink yes I don't know
what it is about Dave filody and calling
people stinky but like Zeb gets called
stinky all the time the night sisters
are calling Sabine stinky yeah and you
know just by the look of the trash that
Ezra has piled on himself that that guy
does not wash his beard there's no
freaking way no no
that guy's a trash monster so my hope is
that he gets a big hug from Zeb and Zeb
is like now you're the one who stinks
like I want people to talk about smell
more
um yeah I I think we have to have a
Rebels read we started to get a piece of
it here uh where Ahsoka it's just
interesting to see Ahsoka hug all these
people because like if you re-watch
rebels she didn't get a ton of time with
everybody no you know she kind of had
that reunion with uh Ezra in the world
Between Worlds I wish they had talked
about it in this episode in episode 7 of
Ahsoka be like hey remember the last
time I saw you was like we were in some
other ethereal space and she could have
been like I was just back there and I
saw Anakin like I want them to compare
notes people just keep not talking about
things like Sabine and she's like we'll
talk about it later it feels like I'm
watching Tommy Wiseau in the room yeah I
don't want to talk about it yeah like
don't worry about it it's like talk
about it this is huge
um so I think like I just had a video
come out on the new rockstars channel on
Friday where I talked about I made the
case for how we could see Freddie Prince
Jr in live action as Kanan yes and the
world Between Worlds I think everything
is set up for it I think we've been
seeing that a publicity photo of Freddie
Prince Jr in like a leather jacket on
the dashboard I think that's what they
use for Kanan they just penciled in a
bit of a goatee or whatever yeah so I we
gotta see like a full Rebels ghost crew
reunion so producer John and I were
having a conversation yesterday talking
about felony and I think that you can
tell that he works out some of his
catharsis of his his middle school
bullying out in these shows because I
think the smell thing I think he was
called smelly as a kid and I also think
at some point somebody took his very
realistic souvenir lightsaber and broke
it because that guy is so against Jedis
using their life he will do anything but
have them use their lightsabers I mean
we've seen some cool lightsaber battles
but he's like I mean he'll have
characters like forego I don't need that
anymore it's like somebody snapped his
Yoda lightsaber over their knee and call
them free Coney or something like that
and like
so or philowner felona I like that
anyway on a happier note what about
those damn witches of death Amir or the
death of Mary what about their magic are
we gonna learn more about them are we
setting up there's got to be I mean come
on Kathleen Kennedy are we getting a
night sisters uh spin-off well no we are
going back in time like the Apple light
takes place in a period where the night
sisters were more active right is that
and where am I mean I would think so I'm
gonna be surprised now going into the
acolyte if the if the Knight sisters
talking about you know Morgan Ellsworth
was like we existed at a time before we
had calendars like yeah so the acolytes
got to tie in with the nice sisters but
yeah I think that might be kind of our
night sister spin-off you know clearly
Disney loves having witch content with
an Agatha spin-off
um yeah we love witches I think uh we're
definitely gonna learn what are in those
containers those coffins or caskets
whatever you think they are that is one
mystery that like if the show does
doesn't show us what's in the caskets I
think that's one that we could be
rightfully upset by is that you know you
gotta open the box
um but I don't know if we're gonna learn
much more about their historical ties
with the zepho
um while it does have the Sith erkatot
language over the door of that pyridian
Fortress
um we also see zepho hieroglyphs on the
background wall of the Coruscant
courtroom and it's just like I just kind
of think the set designers like these
hieroglyphs and like to put them
everywhere and I don't know if we're
meant to like really draw any big plot
implications from that but I I hope I'm
wrong I hope the word zeppo gets spoken
aloud on this show oh yeah absolutely
that would be uh there'll be a big win
for for all of us calcastos fans too
with all the zepho yeah talking uh yeah
Jack was a Jedi fall in order so do we
think that they're going to be able to
land the bird on this one or land the
ghost quote unquote is this all going to
be an Empire Strikes Back style setup
for a season two or or is this part of
filoni's plan Mando verse movie or even
a Defender style team up will there be a
Defender Style team-up Show before the
movie or is the movie the team up what
are we getting here yeah that really is
a good question because you know felony
is the type of Storyteller that it's
really fun to live with him week to week
um but when you look at the like the big
picture of his seasons of content
sometimes the arcs are just all over the
place and you don't really know whose
story we're telling here the show is
called Ahsoka but it's been just as much
a Sabine story it's been just as much an
Anakin story it's been as much like uh a
balance skull story and a thrawn story
there's no clear protagonist and I would
say like Ahsoka has been largely a
reactionary passive protagonist on the
show
um but I do think what's gonna happen is
I would be surprised if we got a setup
for a season two of anything Ezra or
Sabine I think this season's gonna wrap
up the Ezra Sabine storyline I think
they're going to be back on low fall
with a loathe cat feeding it together uh
I think just the way episode 7 ended
with like I'm ready to go home like I
think Iman is founde has been perfect
casting for this show but I don't think
he's someone that like lucasfilm wants
to build like a second season around
um he just came in so late on the show
that yeah he just doesn't seem like
we're gonna follow him for a second
season if we get one
um I think this season's gonna wrap up
that but I think thrawn the fact that
thrawn did come in so late I think
thrawn's gonna make it out of this uh
season alive and that we're gonna end
with thrawn in a position of power and
it's going to either set up a second
season with Ahsoka and thrawn or like
just the thrawn movie and thrawn could
come in as a background character in
season four of the Mandalorian or in uh
or in Skeleton Crew or both I agree I I
think I think you're right that all
signs for the Ezra and Sabine Arc seem
to be like their Destiny is back on
those all right I mean first of all
someone's watching that cat right now
someone's watching that lock cat feeding
it dry food probably no one probably
hasn't had wet food in weeks no idea
yeah it's hopefully it's uh I like to
think it's writer's audience Clancy
Brown yeah kind of trading off shifts
yeah and they're like are you scooping
out the litter box and they're both
they're both claiming that they're doing
it every day but we know they're waiting
like three days
like we all do we have
we house cats uh cats
all right yeah yeah all right let's do a
let's let's end with a little heat check
here before we go to the finale have we
been feeling like what what does this
finale need to deliver to us to make us
feel rewarded on Tuesday night when we
tune into it uh I I think I've overall
I've been feeling good about this show
uh I have enjoyed I have at least
enjoyed every episode
bordered on gleeful Star Wars viewing on
several of the episodes I thought
they've done some interesting things
obviously as it is always the case with
these Star Wars shows and many times
with these Marvel shows there's more I
want more I want things things to be
focused on and there's just not enough
time if everybody ends up back in the
main Star Wars Galaxy with a little
extra Peril to this new Republic that
just seems so blind to any possible
threats to them and we're gearing up for
the next step in the evolution of why
the first order came to be and why uh
the new Republic event foul I'll be
happy as a clan I don't need to see a
major death I don't need to see a major
Revelation I would love I would love
love love the idea of explanation of
force ghosts and how they appear to Jedi
or Force users to continue to be
explored and I know it's kind of a
finale gimmick to have a force ghost as
a reveal but to me it works so I'd love
to see a little more first ghosting but
overall if if the main gang ends back up
in the main Star Wars Galaxy and thrawn
is back and more threatening than ever
I'm happy
yeah I'm feeling similar Tommy I think
this show has been such an interesting
ride week to week
um I've very much enjoyed it and I love
the big swings filoni takes with like
World building and his expansions of our
understanding the Star Wars Universe I
love that we went to a different galaxy
I love that we Revisited the world
Between Worlds that it uh it set up the
promise of a live-action clone wars and
this is all we ever get of a live-action
Clone Wars I'm good I feel like this an
attack of the Clones has me covered it
was so cool to see that and to bring
Anakin back so for the finale I don't
need any big cameos I feel like this
this show between Hayden coming back
with C-3PO I don't need Maul I don't
need Kanan if it gives me that awesome
but I think we need at least I need an
Ezra Zeb reunion I need a big hug
between those two I need to know what's
in the boxes and uh and please if if you
could just give me just uh if you still
have time to edit this episode just put
in a little whisper that Ray Stevenson
can react to in a shot that sounds a bit
like Tom Baker that's all I really want
but like I'm not expecting it I like I
really just think we might have been
getting a lot of race demons and screen
time just to show how good of an actor
he is and that I don't know how much of
a few trees but I think Tommy if they
wanted to explore balance skull in a in
a tales of the Jedi animated episode in
the future could be a cool really cool
Journey for the character yeah I think
we will all watch it but other than that
yeah I don't need big cameos I hope none
of these characters die because they're
all so good
um and I just went thrawn to make one
cool strategic choice that surprises all
of us yes like that's it uh just again
just show how smart this guy is
absolutely we'll leave it there for this
uh first episode of the sneaky
hang on
food I'll never tell who's
who's who's sneaking around oh God
they're gonna give us and make fun of us
I don't care save me internet I don't
care
uh we used to do a segment called find
my shame um I don't know if I want to do
that ever again but remember we used to
do find myself in the backyard buried in
strategic holes all right
um so we got a big week coming up on uh
the new rockstars Network the new
rockstars channel the break room and the
Deep dive we got our Ahsoka reaction to
the finale coming Tuesday night uh we
have our asoki asoki Ahsoka finale
breakdown coming Wednesday uh Loki is
coming uh to Disney plus this week we
got our Premiere reaction coming
Thursday evening and then our uh Loki
Premiere breakdown coming a bit later
Thursday night uh we also over on the
Deep dive we're talking I'm working
currently on a breakdown of James
Cameron's 1986 alien
uh which is a response to my breakdown
of my favorite film Ridley Scott's alien
1979 which you can watch right now on
the Deep dive channel uh and then we
also have a breakdown since it's October
we're doing some horror and uh we're
gonna do Jordan peels get out which my
case the best debut film feature film by
first time director yeah most of the
time directors first films are some
weird project but like Jordan Peele was
able to like perfectly realize His
Brilliant film and that was like his
first movie he had ever made
um so it's an amazing film uh and then
right now I believe you can see new
Rockstar's breakdown of the first three
episodes of gen V on Amazon Prime video
that's the boys spin-off such a good
show and if you guys really love our
breakdown the first three episodes who
knows we might be able to do breakdowns
of every single episode this season but
it's a really cool show check it out
um okay
follow new rockstars on all social
platforms you can follow Tommy at Tommy
Bechtel you can follow me at eavos uh
and we'll see you next week for uh for
more great nerd content thanks for
joining us everybody goodbye
[Music]